people are going to decide if you're
competent or not in less than 100
milliseconds and then it's over so I can
trace my interest in this topic back to
something that happened to me in the
1980s before I was an academic I worked
for a short time in public relations and
found myself one day in a meeting at
nine o'clock in the morning with a very
powerful entertainment industry
executive and he had a little
refrigerator at the edge of his desk
while we were meeting he would open it
up bottle of vodka drank vodka straight
out of the bottle and had a bag of raw
onions he was munching on those while
this was going on and nobody said
anything to him about it
we didn't react while it was happening
we didn't talk about it afterwards he
didn't even offer to share anything with
us seemed perfectly appropriate to him
to behave that way in a meeting with us
would never have occurred to us to do
that in a meeting with him I want to
talk with you about power and I want to
try to provide a new way of thinking
about how to approach situations where
you want to have impact one of the
things that I've observed in my work in
this area is that most people when they
are trying to prepare for a situation
where they want to have influence go
into a meeting or change somebody's mind
is they tend to think a lot about what
they're going to say in that situation
so I'm going to suggest that rather than
thinking about what you're going to say
in situations like this you need to
think about what your body's telling
people when people are forming an
impression of you what you say accounts
for only 7 percent of what they come
away with
what I'd like to do today is to start
first by telling you a little bit about
the actual mechanics of the body
language of power what are the cues that
we send and what do they mean and then
I'd like to talk with you about how you
can think about using those different
cues to address specific challenges and
specific situations there is actually a
body language of power and we know it
but we know it so well that we don't
know that we know it's something that
we've been learning through our
socialization since a very very young
age
so we learn how to tune our bodies to
specific situations and specific
relationships when we need to show
someone respect or be deferential we
know how to use our body in a way that
allows us to be effective in that role
and we learn how to take charge with our
bodies and how to make sure that other
people aren't taking advantage of us
most of us are socialized you know over
the course of our lives based on other
people's expectations of where they
think we should be within a hierarchy
and so we learn how to do certain
aspects of this sort of performance very
well in other parts we know less well
and sometimes we find ourselves in
situations where the things we do with
our bodies that come most naturally
don't fit the situation at all
so I want to raise awareness of the ways
in which we use our bodies and the
impact that it has on our ability to
have power and influence if you want to
be strategic about acting with power
there are two objectives that you have
to keep in mind the first one is that
you want to be able to show up
authoritative in charge able to make the
decisions and able to privilege your
knowledge and experience over the
knowledge and experience of other people
the same time you need to be able to
show approachable which is open
empathetic willing to take others
knowledge and experiences into account
and be able to relate to people on a
human level so let me see if I can start
by giving you a framework for thinking
about two main objectives for addressing
a set of questions about how your body
language can be used to change your
impact there are really two things I
think you need to be able to do if you
want to have influence the first is you
need to be able to show up authoritative
being authoritative means showing up and
letting people know that you're in
charge and what it involves
psychologically and from a body language
perspective is that you're going to be
closing yourself off a little bit to
other people your privileges and
experience over and above the knowledge
and experience of other people you're
becoming more directive and more
concerned with controlling other
people's behavior than from taking
direction from others the second
objective and it's equally important is
that you need to be able to show up
approachable being approachable means
that people feel that they can come to
you with whatever's on their mind and
relate to you on a human level being
approachable is just as important as
knowing how to show of authority it's
really the basis of your likability it's
the basis of the extent to which other
people want to be close to you and it
requires really a totally opposite
orientation from showing up
authoritative it really involves being
more open to other people being prepared
psychologically to relate to them on a
human level and if you think about the
challenge of showing up authoritative as
increasing the psychological distance
between yourself and other people either
by raising yourself a little or by
lowering others a little being
approachable is really about shrinking
the psychological distance between you
and other people it's about lowering
yourself a little or raising other
people up so in the framework that I'm
introducing to you today which I call
acting with power the body language
associated with showing up authoritative
is called playing high and the body
language associated with showing up
approachable is called playing low
the actions associated with playing hi
come from what we observe whenever we
look at animals or human beings in the
context of the social hierarchy when you
look at people with or group members
with high rank what you'll see is a
general body language that reflects a
state of relaxation and openness because
at the top of the hierarchy you have
nothing to worry about
everybody beneath you is going to make
sure that nothing bad ever happens so
playing high in a very general sense
will look like a very open expansive
relaxed body when walking you assume
others will move out of your path taking
up maximum space and allowing your body
and your gestures to flow into the space
of other people other actions associated
with playing high include keeping your
head perfectly still while talking and
speaking in complete sentences so it's
not important when you're playing high
to have long sentences in fact they can
be very short but they'll have a clear
beginning and a clear end point you'll
also see people when playing hi holding
eye contact a little longer than normal
when addressing someone else it's
actually an interesting relationship I
think the idea that staring someone down
is associated with playing high as
something most people know but actually
it's a little more subtle than that so
when you're playing high you stare
someone down when you're addressing them
you don't let them out from under your
gaze they know you're serious but when
they're addressing you you're free to
look around you get other things on your
mind other people you need to talk to
right so when you're being addressed by
other people you're free to look away
you don't check other people's eyes for
any reaction to what you've said and you
have no visible reaction to what other
people say either you can interrupt
before you know what you're going to say
it's important to recognize that playing
high is the source of dominance other
people in many situations are simply
more likely to defer
just based on how you use your body it's
also important to recognize that playing
high can be really dangerous one of the
easiest ways to get in trouble in a
group is to play higher than your actual
rank so the most general advice I can
give about when to play high is that you
play high to reinforce your actual rank
or in a competitive situation when
status is up for grabs
let's talk about what it looks like to
play low when you observe natural
hierarchies and groups what you'll see
is that lower ranking members have a
body language that's exactly the
opposite of what playing high looks like
low ranking members hold their bodies
very close and tight they try to make
themselves as small as they can minimize
their footprint and do sort of prepare
themselves to hide from other people or
kind of fend off a blow so you'll see a
much more an attempt to shrink a little
bit and and hide so when someone's
playing low you'll see them leaning
forward and sometimes point their toes
inward it's all different ways of making
your footprint a little bit smaller
you'll see people speak in incomplete
sentences and when someone's playing low
you get a lot of fleeting and jerky
movements talking with your hands near
your face and instead of looking
directly at someone a lot more glancing
around and looking away they'll talk to
you and just glance over to make sure
that it's going ok but there's no actual
eye contact when a high status person is
addressing a lower status person that's
when the low status person's eyes are
riveted so one of the other really
interesting differences between people
who are higher ranking and lower ranking
in groups is that you see a lot more
smiling from the low ranking members and
it's not because things are better at
the bottom right people in the lower
ranks are smiling because it's their job
to make sure that the people above them
are never uncomfortable so they're not
genuine smiles you get the
kind of a fake apologetic smile it's a
badge of appeasement a way of making
sure that people above them are feeling
okay
playing low is also really important
it's the basis of building rapport for a
low ranking person it's really important
that the people above you know that you
understand your position and you respect
theirs playing low for a high status
person actually makes you more
approachable you can gain status as a
high status person by playing low so
you're most likely to be effective when
playing low if you do it to reinforce
your actual rank or when you want to
lift someone else up
so the next important question is how
should you think about using this and I
can tell you that I use it in two
different ways to make myself more
comfortable in situations where I'm
afraid I'm not going to build a show up
the way I want to and I also use my body
language to help other people feel more
comfortable in situations where I'm
worried about that you can think about
using your body language not to change
the way you show up every day in every
situation but it's a way of beating
specific types of challenges when you
walk into a situation and something
unexpected happens people aren't as
receptive as you expected them to be you
find that you're being attacked or you
can't get someone who you thought was
going to be open to open up and tell you
what you need to know you can think
about how to adjust your body language
to try to shift the dynamic and the
relationship
so when you look at men and women in
leadership roles what you find is that
men and women don't actually behave
differently in these roles they're
perceived entirely differently doing
exactly the same things so let me talk
to you for a minute about women in power
and what that means is that we're
socialized to use the body language
that's associated with having a lower
rank this is not necessarily a problem
it just means that many of us are better
versed in that body language than we are
in the body language of playing hi and
the socialization has implications for
how women are viewed in different types
of roles let me tell you about a study
that was conducted by one of my
colleagues at Stanford he was teaching a
case in his MBA class about an
entrepreneur from Silicon Valley named
Heidi Roizen and she was very successful
and he used the case to illustrate how
effectively people can use social
networks as a way of really building a
business and building a reputation when
his students read this case they were
very negative about her and he was kind
of surprised by that so he thought that
it might have something to do with her
gender so my colleague took the case
about Heidi Roizen and he changed the
name of the protagonist to Howard Rosen
and left all the other details the same
he gave half his students the case about
Heidi he gave the other half of his
students the case about Howard before
they came into class they raided Heidi
or Howard on a bunch of different
dimensions first they were asked how
humble and genuine and likeable was this
person and Howard was the winner of that
contest the second set of questions they
were asked had to do with how
self-interested and power-hungry the
protagonist was and it might not
surprise you to know that Heidi won that
contest the female actor was judge much
more harshly for exactly the same
behaviors as her male counterpart Heidi
and Howard were judged as equally
competent but when asked who they prefer
to work with and who they'd rather hire
the students preferred Howard so the
reason I talked about this case in my
executive education class is because I
think it illustrates
problem that a lot of women face we're
being held to these dual expectations
the expectations associated with our
gender roles require us to behave in the
ways that are associated with playing
low it's expected of us and it's a way
that we can navigate situations where
people want us to make them feel good
because that's what's expected of women
we're also expected in our
organizational roles to behave in ways
they're authoritative so we have to have
those tools available to us and we have
to be able to give ourselves permission
to use them when the situation requires
but I think one of the interesting
possibilities for women is to think
about are there ways of combining those
two different ways of behaving that
allow us to meet both sets of
expectations not necessarily in the same
moment but over the course of our day
over the course of our careers
couple of my colleagues at Harvard and
Columbia did a study they looked at
whether putting people into different
body positions would affect their
psychology in the way they respond to
different types of situations so they
took the participants and physically
posed them either in expansive postures
with their arm across the back of a
chair their feet up on the desk or they
posed them into more constricted
postures where their knees were touching
their elbows were held close to the side
and they had their hands let's say they
were sitting on their hands or between
their knees after two minutes in these
postures my colleagues measured a number
of different things one of the things
they were interested in was in hormone
levels they looked at two hormones in
particular measurements were taken
before the participants were posed in
the posture to get a kind of a natural
or baseline level and then measurements
were taken after two minutes in the
posture they looked at testosterone
levels testosterone is a hormone that's
associated with aggression and dominance
and they looked at cortisol levels
cortisol is the hormone that's
associated with stress and responses to
threat and it's responsible for a lot of
the stress-related illnesses
after two minutes in the posture
participants who were posed expansively
had significant increases in their
testosterone levels and participants who
were posed submissively or in a more
constricted way had significant
increases in their cortisol levels and
you can think about using your body
language to intervene in your own state
of mind
I've had about six months in my new role
and a key component of this job is to
give presentations to fairly sizable
groups of women when I walk into these
rooms I know that I have to be very
centered take up a lot of space use my
voice and project it but stay very
stable and every time I do this it
becomes more natural so I'm trying to
figure out how to find that balance
between friendliness which comes
naturally to me and this display of
competence which I feel like I have and
I should show after taking professor
green fellows class it really opened my
eyes as to when I walk into a room I
need to look around and assess and think
do I want to play high or do I want to
play low when I'm listening it's really
important for me to seem approachable
and open and when I'm presenting I want
to seem authoritative the majority of my
communication with clients takes place
over the telephone including the
all-important client pitch so although
they can't see me
I completely understand how important it
is for me to convey the strong presence
so I'll do three things first is I make
sure that I'm standing up I walk around
the room so I'm not constricted in my
movements I use my body language my
gestures and the third thing is that I
make sure that I project my voice often
I'll talk to junior women about managing
perceptions things this simple is how
you're sitting in your chair are you
sitting with your head tilted to the
side and making yourself small
or are you occupying your space and
making yourself square and big what
about your voice are you going up at the
end of every sentence or are you
speaking in a calm controlled manner are
you making eye contact these things are
all evolutionary cues that help humans
determine one another status and it's
really important to be in control of how
you're perceived I've been a
professional for 25 years is taking the
entire 25 years for me to learn that to
go from authoritative to being
approachable can still produce results
and I think I'm still learning being
successful in an organizational role is
not just about being able to play high
it's not just about being able to play
low it's about being able to recognize
what situations require and to be able
to adapt to those situations what
I'm talking about is making really
subtle kinds of changes this is not
about a major overhaul of your behavior
sometimes it's just about backing off
things that you use in a kind of an
impulsive or knee-jerk way to make
really slight adjustments that you'll
find can have a huge impact in terms of
how their people see you and in terms of
how you behave and how you feel it's
important for women to recognize that
there are dual challenges that we face
one is to meet the expectations
associated with high level
organizational rules and the other is to
meet the expectations associated with
their gender roles it's the balance
between playing high and playing low
that I think makes most managers
effective and this may be especially
important for women I just want to
encourage you to give yourselves
permission to try something new
the next time you feel challenged you go
into a situation where it's important to
you to be seen in a certain way where
you want to have a particular type of
impact think about how you're standing
when you walk into the room think about
how you sit down think about what you're
doing with your head and your eyes when
you're speaking and how you look when
you're listening and see what happens
everything we need is already there
everything we need is already in us it's
just a question of giving yourself
permission to find it and use it
you